Plum Island for 50 years has been the
front line what we call aggro defense
you know protecting the u.s. livestock
detecting the animals and doing the
research on foot and mouth disease only
the other foreign animal diseases it's
critical that we can better understand
what it takes to detect these diseases
and prevent them from spreading you can
you know bring an economy to its knees
by infecting its food supply a 2.8 to
4.2 billion dollar impact to the economy
the end bath is unique at Plum Island
it's the only facility of its type of
duds or an animal diseases and some of
those erotic 2d that we have no vaccines
for in fact we barely know enough about
these diseases and to be able to study
them effectively we need a BSL for what
we call large animals or livestock there
is no existing facility like that in the
country
biosafety level 4 is based on the
pathogen that we work on which have high
risk of life-threatening disease to
humans and some of those visas that go
from the animals and humans are
devastating the human humans could die
if we get those diseases we need to
protect the workers that will be working
on those specific pathogens because
there is no vaccine that they could take
there's no counter measures the risk of
a foreign animal disease of entering the
country are only going to increase such
as the NEPA and Hendra virus we've seen
outbreaks in Australia and Asia so we
need to have that capability
well Milan does not have proximity to
research capabilities it doesn't have
proximity to work force no feasible
evacuation anybody that's ever driven on
the whole island expressway knows there
would be no way the decision maker did
not need to pit the site that had the
least environmental impact he didn't
need to be aware of what those impacts
are